what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel um today i'm
going to be reacting to 12 insane
moments people get caught cheating on
camera before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos also
let me know in the comments if my sound
um and camera is working okay
i got some new equipment and i'm trying
to figure out how to use it so let me
know in the comments
[Music]
relationships are built on trust
or not
fine that doesn't matter let it be trust
unfortunately trust is not always
justified these people have not only
cheated on their partners they also
didn't know how to hide the fact
today we'll show you the most insane
cheating moments ever caught on camera
before we get to these crazy and
hilarious videos be sure to subscribe to
our channel and leave a like after all
you don't want our videos to catch you
by surprise do you
during the lockdown it's hard to
maintain relationships with your loved
ones one spanish reporter appeared in
live broadcast to discuss the pandemic
there was nothing unusual in this
reportage until a scantily clad girl
entered the frame
this caught internet users oh
my god that's so embarrassing
oh my god she can uncover any crime the
woman turned out not to be the
reporter's girlfriend but a co-worker of
his
alfonso immediately laid the blame at
social media because everyone had been
following his relationship with
television presenter martha lopez
that's so embarrassing were they holding
a meeting or did she just pop in to
borrow a stapler
when this couple took their vows
danielle didn't exactly say that if she
was having an affair her husband would
get 8.8 million dollars
but that turned out to be something that
she couldn't avoid
keith king loved his wife danielle but
she couldn't stand their abusive
relationship and wanted a divorce
king didn't want to let his beloved go
and he simply proposed a separation but
soon he began to suspect that his wife
was seeing someone he monitored her
phone and discovered that she was often
communicating with his employee
francisco hazard no she didn't he
decided to have a talk with the guy so
that francisco would stop seeing
danielle however francisco refused to
listen and keith decided to go ahead and
fire this valuable employee
why would you out of all the [ __ ] out
there all the [ __ ] you picked that
bit like in the video king tries to talk
to danielle but francesco won't let him
do it king's wife testified in court
that francisco wasn't guilty of anything
that they had begun a relationship after
her separation from her husband the
court however that was so sad forced
twizard to pay keith 2.2 million dollars
as moral and material damages as well as
a 6.6 million dollar fine
two things you don't want to find in
your home are cockroaches and your
spouse's lover
he just left
but it was obviously no insect that this
guy found his wife in bed with
the woman's lover meanwhile decided to
escape through the window by tying
sheets together a crowd gathered around
and someone called the fire brigade i
wonder why though was it to help the
wife's lover get down safely or to
extinguish the husband's burning rage
[Applause]
[Music]
when we're children that's so
embarrassing in order to see if our toys
come to life
apparently not everyone has moved past
their childhood
one guy coming home from the army found
his girlfriend in bed with another man
the man began a stern lecture about how
he loved his girlfriend and had never
betrayed her even when he had the chance
but be faithful to you there's plenty
opportunities i could have had
but i said no however the girlfriend's
lover lying in bed showed no reaction to
this soldier's speech rather he just
pretended to be sleeping i wonder how
this story ended i hope it wasn't like a
new rambo movie
i loved you lydia i did
go to hell
kiss cam oh
this is it always capture the best
moments but not for this couple
dave was hugging his companion nicely
but as soon as he saw himself on the big
screen instead of a passionate kiss he
abruptly took his hand off her shoulder
this odd reaction made the video very
popular on twitter and then the video
was seen by steve's girlfriend
it turned out that he had gone to the
game with his secret lover the guy later
complained that the video had destroyed
his relationship
okay fellas if you're gonna have a side
chick do it right don't take her to a
bait like a public setting
there's thousands of people you could
run into and see you
many people feel a lack of trust towards
their partners or spouses
this guy decided to check up on his wife
by contacting a young lady by the name
of vika who does fidelity tests on her
youtube channel sergey didn't know what
his wife was up to all day while he was
at work to carry out their inspection
vika and her team installed hidden
cameras in the couple's apartment to
surveil it on day three the camera
picked up a strange conversation the
woman was flirtatiously inviting someone
over to the apartment and she ended her
conversation with the word kisses
the next day the woman spent all evening
preening in front of the mirror and then
a young guy arrived at the apartment i
cannot even imagine how sick i would
feel i would feel so disgusted
now the two lovers are already talking
about how it's time for them to be
together sergey is watching all this on
the screen and immediately he decides to
end the experiment he's boiling with
rage
the lover tries to hide in sergey's own
bed
but sergey is an expert at playing hide
and seek and quickly finds the man the
woman then tries to make excuses but she
is swiftly scent packing
[Music]
what do you think girls get up to when
they meet do they talk about cosmetics
and what an awful outfit am i hot on
today
you haven't guessed right they really
come up with plans for uncovering
infidelity this young lady
decided to check on her i know too much
about that
but she just sent her best friend over
the guy sees her and immediately puts
his arm around her he's caught right in
the act
do i get a hug
sam
is that your big
the guy gets angry that someone's
checking up on him even though his
girlfriend has a lot more reason to be
angry than him first he gave me her ring
and then he got me a new one no actually
first i gave you the ringer
the situation heats up and the
unfaithful man is unable to why are you
mad sir you're the one cheating i'm
against the both of them after all the
only thing worse than one furious girl
is two furious girls
there's a stereotype that women just
don't know how to drive but this woman
knows exactly what a crash test means
she caught her boyfriend with his secret
lover in his range rover the jilted
woman asks the boyfriend to get out of
the car and talk to her but when he
refuses she flies into a rage and begins
to smash up the car
she first breaks the window but they
still refuse to open up but it's like
this range rover is an armored vehicle
or something
[Music]
modern problems call for modern
solutions
john had long suspected that his wife
donna was cheating on him that's why he
decided to tailor her with the help of a
drone discarded
this girl is cheating at him oh my god
the drone video to the internet and good
thing he did
first he watches as his lady takes a
different way to work than usual then
she stops and seems to be waiting for
someone donna starts fixing her hair
this really angered that's smart i did
not think of a drone it's john who's
providing commentary on what he sees on
the screen
the man aggressively shouts that he's
been with his wife for a whole 18
car drives up and she gets into it
without the slightest hesitation
everything is finally discovered she's
caught she don't deserve you king she
don't deserve you but you shouldn't feel
sorry for a woman who in our day and age
gave up a man with a drone for a dude
with a minivan 18 years gone
one guy from peru decided to amuse
himself by going through his town on
google maps suddenly he spots a couple
sitting on the beach or rather the woman
is sitting while the man is resting his
head on her knees it's an adorable scene
right but this man didn't find it so
cute because he realized that the woman
was his wife the faces were heard but he
couldn't help but recognize the person
he'd been living with
when the man showed his wife what he had
found she didn't even bother trying to
deny it she admitted that she had been
cheating on him for several years
google maps had directed them to go
their separate ways
what on earth what do you expect when
you go to a baseball game certainly not
that your affair will be revealed to the
world
a baseball game sisters delana and brynn
were sitting behind a married couple in
the stands the girl's attention was not
on the field but on the phone of the
woman seated in front of them
the sisters noticed that she was sending
a love note to a certain mark but the
contact had been entered into her phone
as nancy
the girls wrote a note for her husband
and they shared their discovery on
twitter half an hour later her husband
already had all the proof apparently to
be a born spy one just has to be born a
woman this is what i'm saying is
literally
it is so much harder to get away with
cheating nowadays
probably the first thing many of us do
in the morning is check instagram
yulia granovich was just scrolling
through her feet and it wasn't kim's new
photos she saw but pictures of her and
her husband's bedroom
the shots had been uploaded by a woman
oh my god the view from my husband's
bedroom is lovely yulia commented on the
photo the instagram drama continued with
a post by yulia where she posted the
same photo from her husband's lover with
a seething caption mentioning him
apparently the story of their love only
survived one instagram story
we hope that you've never been
confronted with cheating
oh my god these are wild let me know
would you guys stay with someone that
cheated on you or would you call it
quits let me know in the comments don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification now that we are
going to be notified of my daily videos
i will talk to you guys next time